I personally feel like maybe three four
three
they need to just focus on one aspect of
Halo not two okay I think maybe if they
directed The Studio they can get because
I feel like they are very good at that
multiplayer aspect they it feels right I
think it's piss-pull and Part of Me Part
of me feels like let someone else do the
single player
that can make Master Chief in a very
single narrative Focus type of story uh
for instance like I If if what I would
like done and I know it probably isn't
gonna go this way and if it was true
that they might have outsourced it but
now they're going back on it and they
like okay let's let's go ahead and
continue to to try to fix this out I
would prefer them to hand it off to like
machine games or someone someone that
has has proven that they can make very
set piece driven narrative focused
single player first person Act